شكراً جزيلاً لك إنه لشرف عظيم
أن يكون لدينا الرئيس عباس من
السلطة الفلسطينية معنا
وممثليه الذين عملوا
بجد مع كل شخص معني من أجل
السلام
، أعتقد أن لدينا فرصة جيدة
جدًا وسأكرس بالتأكيد كل ما
بداخله.  قلبي وداخل
روحي لإبرام هذه الصفقة ، من يعرف
أن أشياء غريبة حدثت ولكن
أعتقد أن لدينا فرصة جيدة وإنه
لشرف عظيم أن تكون معنا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ،
كونلون أمارا الأصلي من وكالة الأمن القومي ، هو خبير دونالد
ترامب السكر في جيرسي  دي ندى
هو منفذ قبعة ملك
قيدان مهراجا الجنرال هاموند
والطريق في صالون أيضًا الذي لديه هذا العمدة
في هونه ، نحن نتعاون معًا في
بالون جانجنام في متجر ثيرمين سعيد بازيلا
فينا وراديو شاربلز ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك.  جميل جدا وهو
شعور رائع جدا بصراحة ودعونا
نرى ما سيحدث حظا سعيدا للجميع
بالتوفيق